there's absolutely no reason to continue
paying for lots of people who have
accumulated wealth their entire lives hi
I'm Nicolas before recent TV and today
we're talking with Veronique to Raji a
reason columnist who covers economics
for us as well as an economist at the
Mercatus Center at George Mason
University Veronique thanks for talking
to us thanks for having me you have
recently talked about how the Occupy
movement while they talk about class
warfare they've got the wrong class who
should they be frustrated with you look
at the data I mean it's obviously
because of government policies there's a
massive transfer of wealth from the
young and relatively poor members of the
society towards the old and relatively
wealthy member of society and
politically connected now in in in 1970
how much in terms of programs that are
designed to help elderly people are
retired people Social Security Medicare
parts of Medicaid in 1970 what was the
percentage of federal spending that was
going to them and what's it going to be
now so roughly twenty percent in 1970s
and today we are at over thirty five
percent when we include Medicaid roughly
a third of Medicaid spending goes to
seniors 2023 the share of government
spending going to the elderly through
social security medicare medicaid will
be fifty percent of this whole budget
and this is you know more than twice as
much as defense spending etc what about
the argument that if we don't keep
spending more money on the elderly
they're going to be living in you know
cardboard boxes they're going to be
eating cat food is that legitimate no
it's not a legitimate issue and concern
and it comes from the fact that usually
when you look at at the elderly and and
and you assess their poverty rates you
look at income and of course when you're
retired and all you don't make an income
usually or it's very small compared to
the income you used to be making when
you actually look at consumption data
and the work that the already have
accumulated and
lot of economists have been looking at
this issue you actually see that this
particular class of Americans their
situations has improved dramatically in
the last 20 30 years and and you also
see that they are faring way better than
the younger Americans who actually are
getting poorer and poorer compared to
the elderly and so what's your preferred
fix to this then if you know if this
system is it doesn't make sense from a
kind of moral point of view and
certainly not from a physical point of
view Medicare is a huge weight of you
know on the federal budget what should
we do I would be in favor of getting rid
of the whole thing taking care of poor
people basically moving away from an
entitlement type situation where
supposedly everyone gets something from
the government and move to true safety
net where we true we take care of the
truly needy there's absolutely no reason
to continue paying for lots of people
who have accumulated wealth their entire
lives and and you know and could be
using this well I want to thank
Veronique to Russia a reason economics
columnist and an economist at the
Mercatus Center at George Mason
University for talking with reasontv
Bernick thanks thanks for reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie